Her low freak bitches.
Just a few people at heard UFC from the
old days and the hoist gracie days and
the um,
the vast majority of the public was kind
of out of the loop and then they put it
on the ultimate fighter and you know,
it was sort of the prime of reality tv
back then.
And that fight between forrest griffin
and Stephan Bonner,
which was such a wild ass fight that
sort of made mma and we really did it
made the UFC and [inaudible] needs
something like that.
They need would if those two played it
safe that night.
It's a good point.
What would we be here,
Joe?
It's a good point.
Where do we beat y'all?
I'd probably be a in Texas right now
doing stand up.
I probably would have never worked for
the,
you probably would have went under.
Yeah man.
I mean keyboard warriors were telling
forrest griffin how sloppy he looked at
night and Stephan Bonner was,
it showed or whatever the fuck they
would say.
You know,
who does a chode does anybody know?
Is that a real thing?
You know what they like to call people
today?
I've known as a cook.
I cook a cock.
That's a big thing.
I said,
well,
you know what it is.
It's like the kids on the Internet have
found a new insult.
Like cock has only been around for like,
yeah,
okay.
See You k w well it comes from a
cuckold,
which is like a guy who likes watching
his wife get fucked by other men,
usually manlier men.
And uh,
how the term Jolie,
I'm online.
I frequented the Internet,
sir to cut,
cut,
cold.
Right.
Might say,
correct me if I'm wrong Jamie,
but I believe that's what it's about.
You know,
who would know,
I wish Jim Norton was here.
He could explain this to us in its
entirety,
but there is a whole genre of porn based
or ah,
around like really nerdy white guys who
have like this smoking hot wife that's
not satisfied.
And some guys like,
shut the fuck up and sit down.
I'm going to fuck your wife in front of
you.
Oh No.
And they cry.
And some of them,
they make the,
they make the husband's suck their Dick.
That happens too.
Well,
yeah,
that's a cook.
That's how,
you know the husband is suck.
His Dick is the cook.
They guy that comes in as much of,
that guy's a stud guy who comes in and
smashes it.
But I dunno if she's a stud,
if he lets the guy stuck his deck.
That's just weird.
Yeah.
That's where it goes deep.
You know,
there's like a spectrum.
Even cock porn,
keeping cocked,
porn has a,
there's a lot of variables they have to
take into consideration.
But I see people calling people cox all
the time.
Like when you're calling another man to
cook as an insult,
what does that say about you and the
porn that you watched it,
you know,
that is,
that just says you frequent like reddit
or something or you're on twitter all
the time.
I mean,
I don't think it says anything about it.
I just think it's,
it's a new thing to call someone to hurt
their feelings.
You know,
like there's no other,
there's no equivalent word.
Like,
it's a new,
it's a new sort of like a classification
of someone to call someone a cook and
you fucking cook.
Yeah.
You,
well now I'm sorry I have to start
calling people that.
No,
don't do it.
Can we just promoted it to the world?
Isn't that kind of thing before and how
it's going to be fucking Holy Shit.
No,
they've been doing it forever.
They're going to call people like
Hashtag powerful cook.
Oh,
you just started something now,
man.
Just made a big mistake.
You know what?
I noticed it a lot when a Kurt Kurt
Metzger,
Ooh,
he's a writer for Amy Schumer show.
He's funny.
Standup comedian.
Very funny guy.
And uh,
he was one of the writers for Amy
Schumer's show when she was getting
accused of plagiarism and all this stuff
was going on and I was seeing all these
people calling them a cock and I was
like,
what is this?
And then I noticed it was like
everywhere.
People call people cooks.
Like everyone's a cook,
Cook.
It's just a phase.
I hope so.
There you go.
So if someone calls you a cook now,
you know,
I was like,
what am I a chicken?
Fuck is that
I don't get it.
Cluck.
Now I will get it.
Oh yeah,
the Internet's,
I don't know all of my,
all the haters.
Now we're going to,
can we call me a cook?
You think?
I don't think it'll work.
It doesn't work.
If you don't like actually watching your
wife get gorilla fuck by some greater,
first of all,
you got to find a dude.
Fuck your wife day.
You can't kick his ass.
That's not,
it's not like a regular Guy Joe
Schilling.
So this is a different sort of scenario.
A real caucus supposed to be like a
feeble person who lets,
I'm a fucking Lawrence Taylor type dude
come into his bedroom and fuck the shit
out of his little white wife.
Uh,
there's a visual for it.
Yeah,
there you go.
That kind of a thing.
You know,
let's Tuck won't work.
I mean then,
but they'll try it on you anyway.
It's,
I mean,
I wonder if we've run out of insults.
I mean it's just cause it's coq one day
using it so often.
Even when it's not,
it's not really applicable.
And they're doing it because it's a new
one.
Like we got a new one just like,
it's not like this makes sense.
Let me call him a faggot.
This makes sense.
Let me call him a pussy.
No,
it's like we've got this world,
it's just throwing around until,
it's almost like they found a new word
and they just throw it and around until
it's useless and we're promoting it
quicker now.
What,
just reporters here,
Joe Schilling was just talking about the
world.
You and I are,
we're essentially journalists.
Yeah.
We're current events journalists.
We're trying and might,
there might be some old folks right now
that it may be,
uh,
you know,
not in the same social groups is us.
Maybe they live in Iowa or something
like that.
And uh,
they just trying to dip their toe into
the rest of the world.
Like what,
what are these kids talking about these
days?
Let me see what a comedian and a
kickboxer have to say about the world.
And then they find out about Cox and
then,
uh,
you know,
their wife later is going through their
google search and she finds cock,
what the hell is it called?
Fuck is a cook.
And then she starts looking up cook and
she finds Kuk Porn.
And then she gets excited and she thinks
my house,
but I don't want,
Oh God,
Oh fuck me in front of him.
I know when I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna set some shit up.
And then she,
uh,
goes on craigslist,
find some dude and she thanks.
You know,
she's fulfilling a fantasy.
Try Spice up the relationship and
suicide,
murder,
suicide probably,
right.
Yeah.
That's,
it's hard to come back from that one.
Kenza how far in that far out in the
sticks we're talking about what does a
deal with Ahmad Ahmad,
it's called a model.
Got just the kitty thing.
Cox and mods cucs a months.
Furries I'm starting to cook is not
going to catch on.
I still don't get it.
Still like still good cook,
but she just call the Guy Cock your cock
sucker fucking nope,
nope,
nope.
You fucking cook.
Yeah,
they like it.
It's a new word.
It's exciting news.
Let him use it.
The people haven't had a new word to
call people and so long and they're
trying to take away so many of them.
It used to be when I was a kid,
you can call a kid a Faggot,
you know,
and now you gay bashing.
Yeah.
Back then it had nothing to do with
being gay,
but it's too late.
That's connected to that.
It's really hard to use.
Retard.
It's hard to use.
No today.
You know,
even though it's not even a
classification for mental illness has
nothing to do with down syndrome.
Like retarded means slow growth,
like slow to catch on.
It is literally the perfect word to use
for retards when someone's a retard,
like calling them a retard is a perfect
word.
Like you would never say that about
someone who has a disease or someone who
has down syndrome,
but if someone's like it wants trump
wins,
ward people talking over,
that's where retired.
That's a retard,
right?
Fucking radar.
It's the right word.
It's the word.
These goddamn language police
motherfuckers,
they've,
they've typed sensitive to sensitive
punch of Cox fucking sensitive cucs
they've traded debt catch up.
Maybe I do like it.
It's fucking,
we need a new card.
I'm happy.
It's horrendous.
That actually works in the description.
Right.
It's weak little bitch that would let
some other man fuck his wife.
Yes.
Same Person.
It would be like,
oh,
don't call him a retard.
Exactly.
We need to be more sensitive about the
way we communicate both they're really
trying to do is just control people.
It's a trend.
It's the pussification.
Yes.
The goddamn pussification of America.
I see something in America that's like
the whole world,
the whole world fucking pussification of
everybody.
Oh yeah.
Well,
and it's also not not being honest about
what the fuck's going on.
You know,
like when something happens,
we have to be real sensitive to who we
insult post post,
like attacks.
Like with shit that was going on in
Germany where all these women were
getting raped during New Year's eve cut
because of all these Islamic refugees
that they had come in from Syria.
I mean,
it's just,
that's just the way it is.
[inaudible] people are coming from a
completely different culture in their
culture.
Women are much more suppressed.
They come over to this country,
Germany,
where women are Western eyes,
they're free and they're wearing skirts
and their tits or hanging out and way
they're dressed normal and getting
attacked,
and so what is the fucking mayor of?
Was it Berlin?
Tell them,
stay away from men and dress different,
stay an arm's length away from men and
dress more conservatively.
Like literally this fucking,
these people are so sensitive and
worried that they're going to hurt
someone's feelings or they're going to
be called Islamophobic or racist in some
way,
that they're,
they're telling women who've done
nothing wrong,
that they should dress differently
because they've unfortunately let these
people in from another culture that
think about things differently.
Yeah,
a bunch of Cox fucking Cox sensitive
dazzle,
the mayor of Berlin or wherever it was,
it was a woman.
Was it Berlin?
I remember when the city was,
but that's a woman,
so it's even more confusing.
But boy did she get fucking raked over
the coals online.
People are getting tired of it.
The pendulum swings both ways.
You know,
it swings towards ultra sensitivity and
then people get sick of that and they
go,
what the fuck?
And then they go hard the other way.
I think that's one the reasons why trump
is the republican nominee.
I think Caitlyn Jenner is responsible
for a lot of it.
I think people saw that and they're
like,
what the fuck?
They just like,
what?
What are you doing?
What do you,
what does this 62 year old man now he's
a woman,
call me kate on the cover of Vanity
Fair,
going to be naked on the cover of sports
illustrated.
And then she went like athlete of the
year,
fuck,
get the fuck out of it.
She was a woman of the year.
Yeah,
woman of the year should a woman for a
week.
She winds women of the year just shows
you men can do everything,
including could.
When women in the year be this cock.
Jamie pulled up the fucking definition.
Is this an urban dictionary?
What's a better definition?
I think that the one you gave,
oh,
how dare you?
A demasculated millennial liberal male
who often speaks of white privilege and
modern feminism blames white men for all
of the world's problems.
Hmm.
It's the new definition there,
but now
I like,
I like this though.
There it goes chat again with the
megaphone telling everyone that he's a
Vegan.
What a cook.
Okay.
I like that.
I liked that a lot.
But um,
look up cock hold,
but cock hold is different.
It's a different,
uh,
short for conservative.
What fucking the word cock is most
commonly used on twitter to describe
anti white males while it was originally
formed with the original meaning of Kack
Kack hold the use of the word cock does
not necessarily denote a sexual
connotation.
Wow.
It's morphing.
The language is evolving before our
eyes.
Cox do not care about Islamic countries
throwing gays off buildings or hanging
them as much as the cake Baker who is
Christian and weren't served gay wedding
customers.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Coxe.
Give a free pass to anyone who
criticized them for fear of looking
racist or homophobic.
We'll still have that lady in Germany is
a cook.
The word originated from white
nationalists vocabulary.
But he's still widely used by all.
Okay.
But that,
so,
but they took cock hold and turned it
into this new thing go to.
But what does cut the definition for KOC
hold?
So this has nothing to do with guys'
wives getting bang by just to me,
it's still real to me.
Damn it.
I was also like an official definition
that I'm like a little dictionary from
old English.
Oh,
it means a man whose wife was
unfaithful.
Yeah.
Cuckold which is,
yeah,
yeah.
To make a cuckold of,
so if you,
okay,
that's uh,
that's how Norton I think described it
to me like a man,
if you,
if your wife is out banging other dudes
and you know about it,
but you don't say anything,
you become a cock hold.
But there's also like cock hold porn
where it's like I said,
the guys there while like sobbing in the
corner while his wife gets grilled,
fucked.
Interesting.
The world is evolving.
It's beautiful.
So it's still open,
open season then for use cook anyway you
want,
because we were really just hit like
five definitions.
I still have a fucking clue.
I mean,
yeah.
a bunch of cooks it of cooks.
I liked that one definition though.
The the,
the Vegan,
it's gets on the megaphone.
It's usually a Vegan who's been a Vegan
for like a month to,
all right.
Those are my favorite fucking Cox.
I can cook.
Boy,
how do you pull out of this and have a
normal conversation?
Where do we go from here,
jo?
Where did we go?
Okay.